hi guys Dr Burke here in this video
we're going to discuss and talk about
how to get rid of the residual pain from
shingles it's actually really simple
once you know how but unfortunately
there's it's really hard to find
Solutions out there if you do searches
there's drugs there's different therapy
but it doesn't really work uh pain from
shingles should normally go away but a
lot of times it doesn't so here's the
thing first of all shingles pain comes
from a virus viruses are very very
different because they they're not
really like bacteria they're not alive
they are a piece of genetic material
wrapped in a sack and they're activated
by your own cells so if you had the
chickenpox early on they travel through
the nervous system end up in a certain
nerve usually in the nerves around the
ribs in the back and the front and they
just hang out there and they wait and
they wait until you get stressed tired
broken down and older and then they come
out and they kick your butt they affect
the the nerve root or the nerve and they
affect the skin skin lesions as well so
it's very very nasty stuff okay so I'm
going to show you a technique to knock
out the residual pain it also works for
acute pain as well but also to keep that
virus in remission because you can't
kill it all you can do is keep it in
remission okay I'm going to show you how
to do that as well
all right so here's the principle we're
looking at someone's back let's pretend
that your shingles pain is on the right
side in the midback and it comes around
your back under your arm to the front
okay it could be on the left side it
could be a little higher it could be
lower so you're just going to take the
concept here and try to understand what
we're going to do if the pain is on the
right side what we're going to do is
we're going to do a little bit of like a
massage or
acupressure on the opposite side over
here so you want to work on the mere
image side okay and I'm going to show
you in a second how to demonstrate that
so you're going to wherever it hurts
over here you're never going to press
where it hurts you're never going to
press where the skin lesion is you're
going to press on the opposite side now
we're just talking about pain here so
you just have to isolate where does it
hurt now let's say it hurts right here
then you're going to press on the mere
image side right over here and you're
going to work out and any type of pain
that you have in this side but on the
opposite okay now in this video I'm not
going to show you why this works it's
just going to work and you could put
your comments below and you'll be quite
amazed how fast you can knock out pain
there's some things you need to know
though if you if it hurts on this side
and you press on the opposite Mirror
Image side it's going to be twice as
tender as if you press on this side so
another words you're going to be quite
surprised how tender it is on the good
side yeah I know it's weird but you're
going to just keep working it out and
you're going to have to have someone do
this on you because it's going to be
hard for you to reach back there I mean
you probably can get a tennis ball or
something but you want someone to just
massage on the opposite side all the way
through the front side until there's no
more pain here it should take close to
about two or three minutes okay uh I've
never had a case where it didn't work so
um and we're just talking about pain
here if there's skin lesions that's a
whole different thing but as long as we
get rid of the pain that would be a good
thing so I have my um person to
demonstrate this on right now so let's
have you come over here so you could
stand right like this okay good so I
want to make sure the camera is okay we
got the camera on this okay so let's
pretend the Pain's over here and it
wraps right around we're going to be
massaging on the opposite side I would
have the person laying face
down and working out wherever it is on
this side you do it on this side and and
it travels down a nerve okay and there's
going to be a couple spots that are
going to be excruciating so you want to
go light at first and just kind of work
it out to their tolerance and you just
massage all the way around on the nerve
root now the key the little secret to
this is that there's like a lot of times
you have a band of pain what you want to
do is find the epicenter of this pain on
this side on the good side when you
press it won't hurt unless you press and
you just work that out and you find that
nerve there's going to be like around a
rib you're going to find one rib that's
going to be so painful so you're just
going to stick on that and massage it
and follow it
down around through here okay so
now if it's around the front part let's
say it's it's around
here what we'll do you can just hold
that there we're going to work on the
rib and work on the front part too and
we'll massage that right through in here
so we're just going to mirr image
stimulate the opposite side where that
pain is on this side okay thank you so
do you got the concept um you're
basically just working on the mirror's
image size no one does this they do
therapy on the pl the part that hurts
well it doesn't work like that this will
knock it out and it has to do with
what's happening to the brain that
there's a stuck flow of pain through
there and by pressing the opposite side
you're sending signals out to the brain
because the nerve that goes down this
side actually crosses over the spinal
column and connects to this side they're
on the same circuit so if you work on
the other side of the circuit you can
knock out pain on this side and that
kind of neutralizes that stuck flow and
that's what pain is okay so that's
that's how you knock out the pain now
what do you do to improve and keep it in
remission okay so a there's a deeper
issue I want to show you out of this
book right here siba okay this is by
Frank net MD this is a this is on the
adrenal chapter the adrenal gland is on
top of the kidney there're stress glands
and the adrenal and it has a little part
where talks about the adrenals control
the susceptibility to viral
infections that is why when you go
through
stress and you knock out the adrenal
gland because adrenal gland is the
stress gland the viruses can come out of
remission so what you want to do long
term is start building up your adrenals
okay do things to improve the adrenals
to really keep that virus in remission
because viruses people that get immune
weaknesses or they're susceptible to
viruses usually have weak adrenals so
you want to strengthen that there's a
there's a link down below of a kit that
I use um to strengthen the adrenals it's
more uh corrective but there's a quick
little thing you can do to knock the
pain out nutritionally it's vitamin D3
okay don't use vitamin D2 it's D3 but
you need about 50,000 international
units okay a day now you might say
that's a lot well what's happening is
vitamin D is intimately connected to
your immune system and it's what happens
is that when you increase vitamin D you
can push that virus back in
remission okay um in fact think about
let's just think about a couple things
uh when do people get the flu which is
usually viral in the fall right like
November why isn't it coincidence when
you start dropping you go from the
summer months which is all the sun
vitamin D to no sun it drops vitamin D
making you more susceptible to getting
sick yeah that's why so there's a huge
connection also with um cervical um uh
there's a certain virus that comes out
in the cervix and it comes out in the
fall too it's pretty interesting so
viruses tend to come out when there's
low vitamin D levels so um I'll put a
link down below of what I'm talking
about but the point is that when you
take vitamin D in higher amounts you can
a lot of times push the virus in
remission but anytime you take vitamin
D3 you need Vitamin K2 why because they
work together if you take too much of
this you'll you'll get soft tissue
calcium deposits in the wrong places so
K2 drives the calcium in the right
places into the bone and it works
together with vitamin D and You' need
500 micrograms get the mk7 version the
combination of this take it in the
morning would be very very good to help
keep that thing in remission and then
also work on your adrenals okay so go
ahead and apply this technique and put
your comments
below